this video is brought to you by Verve
hey wisecrack Helen here so Jared's
taking a breather this month which means
I have the honor of telling you guys all
about one of the most beloved and
fan-requested animes in wisecrack
history Cowboy Bebop
yes we're finally doing it so what's
taking us so long well when we sat down
to analyze what makes Cowboy Bebop so
amazing
from its super fluid fight scenes - it's
insane grab bag of a soundtrack we kept
running into the same problem every
episode is the kaleidoscope of
references philosophies narratives and
forms it seemed downright impossible to
pull on just one thread then around the
beginning of season 2 we noticed this
interstitial yeah it might be hard to
read but it says then in 2071 in the
universe the bounty hunters who are
gathering in spaceship bebop will play
freely without fear of risky things they
must create new dreams and films by
breaking traditional styles the work
which becomes a new genre itself will be
called Cowboy Bebop
it's those last two sentences about
breaking traditional styles and creating
a new genre that really gave us pause
see Cowboy Bebop isn't just about great
characters and deep thoughts
it's about blurring the line between
three distinctive genres sci-fi westerns
and noir so welcome to this wisecrack
edition on cowboy bebop and you guessed
it spoilers ahead and thanks again to
our sponsor Verve there your one-stop
shop for anime science fiction and so
much more if you're a Cowboy Bebop fan
be sure to check out their new show
killjoys to get your bounty hunters and
space fix for a free 30-day trial go to
burro slashed wisecrack now back to the
show first a quick refresher course said
in the year twenty seventy one cowboy
bebop follows a group of starving bounty
hunters who wander from planet to planet
looking for their next meal ticket
there's jet a former detective who's
rockin the Robocop look on his left arm
spike a modern take on the Marlboro Man
mixed with the tragic mob backstory they
authentic tall dealing with gambling
problems and a serious case of amnesia
and um ed who's a brilliant hacker
but really yeah she's just it together
in more or less episodic fashion the
team hunts down fugitives while
shoveling down some pretty meager meals
new Canadian Jordana ginger roast why
you are in Johnny no hana aside from an
ongoing fight with hunger the first
thread you'll notice in Cowboy Bebop is
its unique take on the sci-fi genre the
show challenges our idea of sci-fi by
presenting a future that doesn't really
have much to do with the future sure
they're all the familiar trappings here
after the destruction of a giant space
portal that lets you travel the universe
at near light speed earth has been left
near uninhabitable and mankind has
spread throughout the universe and for
those of you who grew up on things like
Star Wars or Gundam Wing you'll notice a
medley of conventions epic space battles
check terrifying mysterious alien
creatures check space terrorists sure
why not but the longer you inhabit the
world of Cowboy Bebop the more you
realize its brand of sci-fi isn't about
portraying the future in fact it feels
more like the 90s than it does 2071
cities here aren't the shining beacons
on the hill that futurism promised us
instead they're dirty almost rundown
hell there's a whole space colony full
of drifters and riffraff and technology
isn't exactly 70 years ahead of its time
either take session 7 for example heavy
metal Queen in it we see the ins and
outs of space transportation through the
lens of the best trucker there is VT but
it quickly becomes apparent that much
hasn't changed for future truckin space
trucks are still adorned with hood
ornaments their cabins are still cramped
two-seaters crammed with personal
knickknacks
they even communicate via radio hello
Japan - Herrera si estas Rosetta radio
people and when it's time to wind down
there relax at crappy rest stops which
look identical to the ones I've seen in
West Tennessee so what's going on here
what are we to make of a sci-fi that
doesn't really make use of the science
part in a flashy er way as wisecrack
favorite Ray Bradbury tells us science
fiction is the fiction of revolutions
revolutions in time space medicine
travel and thought above all science
fiction is the fiction of warm-blooded
human men and women sometimes elevated
and sometimes crushed by their machines
in other words at the heart of any good
sci-fi story then are the people and
their stories in which machines are only
a part Bradbury's words go a long way in
explaining why we continually see
stories and cowboy bebop that are
surprisingly light on the technology
that surrounds them perhaps there's no
better example of this than Faye
Valentine
in many ways Faye is a victim of
scientist progress when she and her
family travel to space aboard their
private shuttle
something goes horribly wrong leaving
Fay as the only survivor but her
injuries are so severe that doctors
decide to cryogenically freeze her until
she can be saved by later medical
advancements over 50 years pass and Fay
is awoken by the questionably name
physician dr. Bacchus except there's
only one problem
hey Fiona no no no no no no no yep she
lost her memory worse because the gate
exploded while she was frozen
there's no surviving data on who Fay
even was before adidas DejaVu machine de
mauvoisin a team of local italica walk
our union activist and we mentioned she
is now drowning in debt Chucky who Tonio
yet despite Science and Technology
nearly screwing Fay at every turn Bay's
story is never folded into a warning
about the future or its technology
instead phase journey is all about
finding a place to belong a pretty
common literary trope across all genres
Nessie kioku Madonna demo equal to 19
anumana katha kaadu Bachchan ante da
Cunha munakata sure elements of science
fiction set up phase narrative but at
the end of the day they're just silent
cues that help move the conflict along
by letting science elements do their
work in the background Cowboy Bebop
really thrusts its characters into the
spotlight which is maybe why with only
10 out of 26 episodes exploring our
hero's personal stories we're still able
to relate so much to them seriously guys
who did not feel like crying when Fay
just lies down in the wreckage of her
childhood home but sci-fi isn't the only
genre Cowboy Bebop works in
[Music]
yeah if the title wasn't enough of a
dead giveaway
Cowboy Bebop also plays heavily with
Western conventions more than anything
the first session asteroid blues really
sets the tone in the episode jet and
Spike hunt down the drug dealer Asimov
soul and son and his girlfriend Katarina
in Tijuana
there are saloon fights in Stetson hats
indigenous wise men we even see spike
wearing a poncho and sombrero at one
point and true to form even the episodes
ending itself is an homage to classic
Western themes Katarina realizing the
jet and the authorities are closing in
on them decides to take drastic action
[Music]
as literary critic Peter French notes
while rare when suicide is depicted in
westerns it is shown to be the escape of
the week or the defeated for French
though nothing characterizes westerns
more than the death and that's
particularly true in cowboy bebop French
rites the Western is about a dead man's
walk or run or gallop it is not
accidental that so many of the heroes
and villains of westerns are portrayed
as having a previous history in the
American Civil War on the losing
Confederate side they have been defeated
and lived with death and gore in a cause
they we are led to believe Saul either
as their inescapable duty or as romantic
this concept of a dead man's walk
becomes particularly relevant with spike
just as Western heroes aimlessly wander
through life carrying the burden of the
romantic cause which has now been
extinguished so - to spike meander
through life carrying his tragic romance
with him a romance that almost killed
him
the first detail we learn about spike is
that he's already died once before
a former hit man for the Red Dragon
syndicate spike wanted to escape with
the love of his life Julia after
performing one laugh
job except Julian never showed up and
the spikes partner well let's just say
he's named vicious for a reason in the
end spike barely managed to escape with
his life
with everyone in his old life believing
he died but instead of washing his hands
of everything spike holds on sandy goo
honey whatever all in all NOLA just as
French described with westerns spike can
never fully tear himself away from his
bloody past whether it's to bring a
bounty on his former boss or my mom
because she say what he thought thought
or to chase after the woman he loves or
to settle the score with vicious spike
returns time and time again to his past
considering spike nearly dies every time
he runs after his past we've got to
wonder what duty could be so important
especially since he once told Faye that
the past doesn't matter anymore I'm
gonna check the huh though there's a
little girl talk about the water me
doubt you out at all well digging deeper
into the genre the answer isn't too much
of a stretch as literary critic Jane
Thompkins notes in her book west of
everything the heroes and villains of
westerns aren't concerned with
traditional judeo-christian ethics with
the harsh reality of the desert and
their outlaw lifestyles won't allow it
instead their moral code revolves around
honor as French elaborates what after
all is the value of residents in the
kingdom of heaven if the cost is one
self-respect
we see this in almost every character
from spikes past but most vividly in
vicious vicious after the sociopath
holds a mite is right attitude those who
can't or won't fight according to
Misha's shouldn't be allowed to live
it's the reason why he killed his boss
and later staged a coup it's also the
reason why he seeks to kill spike the
man who has renounced his violent past
when you are war at all not even a
little bears not human
some of you community
so much trouble Christopher no no but
even vicious seemingly wants a fair
fight with Spike he passed up easy
opportunities to kill his mortal foe
when spike was passed out on one of
Jupiter's moons vicious leaves him
unharmed mesito na marathon wound on off
and when spike and vicious are in their
final duel they both passed their own
preferred weapons to each other instead
of either taking the advantage as for
spike his decision to kill vicious isn't
about him being a serious piece of [ __ ]
in part it's about writing a personal
wrong Julia's death as French reminds us
the hero of a Western is not the cowboy
equivalent of the Caped Crusader the
wrongs must always relate to some harm
suffered either by him directly or by
someone with whom he has established a
relationship but there's also a more
philosophical reason behind Spike's
decision and it has to do with
skepticism since leaving the syndicate
spike has wondered if he ever really
survived at all wondering if what he saw
was real
decoding acoustic guitar bot scream
under
somebody I don't know I got the whole
new me de cacahuate de Maurepas de mo
data many Mia telephone talking at King
decision I specifically spiked
continually floats the idea that
everything he sees could just be a dream
although summer night you only did like
I said in this sense spike echoes the
skepticism of ancient Chinese
philosopher Kwang soo who wrote once
upon a time I wander dreamt there was a
butterfly fluttering hither and thither
to all intents and purposes a butterfly
I was conscious only of my happiness as
a butterfly unaware that I was wrong
soon soon I awaked and there I was
veritably myself again now I do not know
whether I was then a man dreaming I was
a butterfly or whether I am now a
butterfly dreaming I am a man spike
struggling to make sense of life before
and after the syndicate wonders if maybe
he never really left the syndicate at
all he wonders if he really died that
night it's only after losing the love of
his life that he accepts the cruel
reality of the situation he's been awake
the whole time
[Music]
some attracted for spike his dead man's
walk isn't just to take revenge on
vicious it's paradoxically to show
himself that he's awake or as he tells
PHA shitty Nia Cougars are they ordering
a home to me to Coco and while it's up
for debate whether spike dies after his
final fight with vicious I've got to say
spike would make Clint Eastwood proud by
storming vicious his hideout
oh and wondering why Vicious and Spike
can go at it with the katana and a
pistol and the whole fight still feels
believable yeah it's because Ronan films
you know Japanese period pieces that
follow the lone samurai dispensing
personal justice are pretty much the
cultural equivalent of westerns in fact
from the epic one-man armies to the
tenth silence before the duel westerns
and Ronan's have created a fairly shared
visual and thematic identity but that's
another video finally the third and
perhaps most notable genre Cowboy Bebop
works in is no are strangely noir is
notoriously hard for film critics to
for example Raymond Borden Etienne
shamaton defined it in their seminal
text a panorama of American film noir as
having five key characteristics
dreamlike strange erotic ambivalent and
cruel but many popular noir films don't
get all the marks while every character
is influenced by film noir Jimmy no
meanie it's the book we come by
I think the genre has the greatest pool
on Faye and jet sorry spike Faye is
clearly a femme fatale one of film noir
favorite conventions see when film noir
first captured the popular imagination
following World War two there were few
representations of women that depicted
them is anything other than swooning
fainting walking pairs of ovaries but as
literary scholar Jaime place notes the
war changed that and became one of the
few periods of film in which women are
active not static symbols are
intelligent and powerful if
destructively so and derive power not
weakness from their sexuality they is
definitely intelligent powerful and
sexual she's constantly one step ahead
of her male peers and she isn't above
using her sexuality to get what she
wants and while some like critic Julie
Grossman have criticized the trope for
being an overly simplistic reduction of
lady agency in the world
Faye is a little more dynamic in fact
she's the only character who really
makes a substantive internal change by
the series end but her narrative arc
also taps into the very philosophical
spine of noir nihilism yes I know
nihilism has become wisecracks favorite
dead horse but hey I didn't put it in a
zeitgeist
according to literary critic mark Conrad
noir developed as a consequence of the
20th century assuring
old bleep systems when Nietzsche
famously proclaimed God is dead he was
making a statement that these seemingly
eternal systems like God morality or
even truth were illusions reality to
Nietzsche is in constant flux which
means things like definitions constants
and even being don't exist over time
whether he was right or wrong Nietzsche
was correct in predicting the mass
alienation and loneliness brought on by
the disillusionment of these systems as
science chipped away at our happy belief
systems in the 20th century people
became lost and anxious and wisecrack
was born
Conrad writes seeing noir as a response
or reaction to the death of God helps
explain the commonality of the elements
that critics have noted in noir films
the inherent pessimism alienation and
disorientation and if there's one
character who's continually had belief
system after belief system ripped away
from her it's faith when faith first
awakes she doesn't actually believe that
she's in the future that is until here
lawyers tell her that she's got it all
wrong
you know how much you said no because
you hutchins in this sort of got a
psyche you know what about Teddy B Dylan
aku Center keys and if waking up in an
unrecognizable future sounds bad try
adding trust issues when Fay finds out
that her old lawyer you know the one she
fell in love with had faked his death
you can bet your bottom dollar that she
felt the same lonely anxiety that
Nietzsche had described
don't go so Nana and Fay experiences the
ultimate disillusionment when she finds
out that the goals she's been searching
for her past is gone after Edie take
Spade to the place where she grew up
the two were greeted by an old classmate
emphasis on old time like Nietzsche's
idea of reality is in constant motion
and it's left Fay behind realizing that
she can never get her old life back Fay
calls herself a ghost
hmm ah she later tells spike the life
that she thought she wanted the home
that she wanted to return to is no more
Faye is not the only noir s character
who's a trench coat wearing cop who
remembers his sweetheart like this
yeah it's everyone's favorite chef jet
like Faye jets backdrop borrows heavily
from noir conventions a former cop jet
suffered two massive blows in his past
first his lover walked out on him
without warning would in a quiet
external some tokidoki not know go Tito
touch to sayonara to rock a concrete
enemy to eat soon you know and second he
was nearly killed when he cornered a
syndicate assassin oh and did I mention
Jets nickname
so we've got a former cop turned P I I
mean bounty hunter who's pining over a
lost love
yeah it's no are like Faye jet has to
learn the time moves forward and with it
everyone else consider the pocket watch
the Jets lover Alisa left him another
Munakata Ganymede energy automata mama
[Music]
though he macaws no harness you whoa
Mothra da
[Music]
Logan a cigar you don't know
while the symbolism might be a bit
heavy-handed here jet holding on to the
broken watch represents his desire to
return to the past to a time when his
watch still ticked and melesa waited for
him to come home from work but when jet
seeks answers about the past he's
reminded that it's long gone ELISA has a
new life and a new boyfriend an only jet
is wondering why worse when ELISA
finally gives jet the answers he's
looking for they shatter his ideas of
the past as it turns out jets
relationship wasn't so perfect and ELISA
felt trapped the room was it that's
unanimous knock do Khatami tiny bikini
anata no Denise come up if I picked up
in the end jet can't return to his past
because this idealized past never
existed at all looking back at that
interstitial about playing without fear
of risky things breaking traditional
styles and creating new genres it's hard
to argue that series director Shinichiro
Watanabe didn't do just that in Cowboy
Bebop sci-fi westerns noir even a little
Ronin action it's all here and it's all
excellent it's this very John rebending
that's made the series so popular and
it's the reason why Cowboy Bebop seems
so fresh two decades later and there's
nothing like a story that can withstand
the test of time if Cowboy Bebop Scott
you feeling nostalgic get excited you
can find all your old favorites plus
tons of great new series on Verve
Dragonball super mega lo box Cowboy
Bebop one piece and tons more personally
I'm a subs overdubs kind of gal one of
the best things about verb is that it
gives you both and when you've had your
fix of anime there's so much more to see
like all 354 episodes of Star Gate or
the story of another space Bounty Hunter
crew in the new show killjoys from
sci-fi with first premium you'll even be
able to watch all your shows on the go
without internet for a limited time get
a 30-day free trial of birth premium at
Bercy
/ wisecrack this will give you ad free
access to 13 channels such as
crunchyroll roosterteeth Funimation
cartoon hangover DramaFever curiosity
stream and more their latest channel mix
flat even features throwback episodes
from 90s Nick interested yet check it
out by heading to Verve CEO slash
wisecrack or clicking the link in the
description that's all for now see a
space cowboy